i want to give you six exercises for a
double chin now as we age or gain weight
a lot of times we get a little loose
skin underneath here and it can develop
into a double chin so with anyone that
has a double chin i would highly
recommend you start with
healthy keto and intermittent fasting
because that's going to actually help
you take the weight off and then in
addition to that start doing these
exercises you can find the diet right
down below in the description
so let's go through these exercises
number one i recommend something called
the straight jaw jut exercise
okay that would be something you can do
[Music]
number two the ball exercise you can try
that
[Music]
number three the exercise called pucker
up
[Music]
number four
tongue stretch
[Music]
number five the neck stretch
number six the exercise called bottom
jaw jut so you can go ahead and pause
this video and practice these exercises
uh personally i'm not going to
demonstrate these for you you can just
watch the video so go ahead and try
these a few times a day over the next
couple weeks and then comment down below
of the improvements that you observe
hey before you go
if you're benefiting from any of my
content
i would love to hear about your success
story
please share it in the link down below